[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es ein rezept ich glaube es
ist ein richtig gutes party rezept denn
ich werde diesen laugen kranz zubereiten
der laugen kam es reicht locker als ich
würde mal sagen wenn sie jetzt nur den
kampf gibt locker für sechs bis acht
personen aber wenn es noch was dabei
gibt also party buffet zb dann auch
locker für 30 leute ich hab den kranz
ganz verschieden belegt zuerst natürlich
den lauben kann selber gebacken das ist
ganz wichtig und dann habe ich jetzt
jedes viertel anders belegt aber mit
lachs einmal mit avocado mit putenbrust
und mit käse und das ist wirklich eine
richtig coole idee vor allem für eine
party für ein büfett wir hatten das auch
auf dem lehrerzimmer wenn jemand
geburtstag hatte zum glücklichen
morawitz nicht da weil der wird dann
sagen bei uns auf der arbeit da gibt es
so was nicht wir haben arbeiten und wir
haben keine zeit für feiern
aber bei uns war für da hat jeder immer
mal was mitgebracht und ja das ist eine
richtig coole idee ich habe den kranz
bereits gestern schon gebacken das heißt
ihr müsst euch auch nicht am tag der
party hinstellen und noch auspacken
sondern ihr könnt gut vorbereiten
bei uns ist heute so miraß einschulung
und heute abend bekommen ist an die
gäste zum essen
ich zeige euch jetzt einmal die zutaten
für den hefeteig dann zuerst einmal muss
ich den laugen kranz backen und den
hebesatz zu bereiten für den hefeteig
brauche ich 200 milliliter warmes wasser
einen würfel hefe 30 zum zucker 30 gramm
zuckerrübensirup oder honig zb zweier
260 gramm war mit vier teelöffel salz
160 gramm sonnenblumenöl und ein kilo
mehl
zuerst will ich jetzt den hefeteig und
dafür gebe ich jetzt das warme wasser
bereits in der rührschüssel wir können
den tag aber auch gerne mit der hand
verkneten
da kommt jetzt die hefe mit rein und
direkt auch dass zucker und jetzt kann
das ganze verrührt werden
jetzt kommen hier doch die restlichen
zutaten mit rein zuckerrübensirup auf
jeden fragen der bringt einfach nur mal
so einen kräftigen geschmack mit rein
dann auch die eier
normalerweise gehört ja nicht in einem
boot aber das einfach den teig einfach
super weit jetzt noch die milch das nähe
und auch bereits das öl und jetzt kann
ich den teig in etwa sieben bis zehn
minuten zu einem geschmeidigen teig
verkneten
[Musik]
jetzt ist der teig verknetet und jetzt
kann ich hier meine arbeitsfläche und
bisschen entfetten können sie auch
wählen und der teig ist schön weich
sollte aber auch nicht mehr kleben also
das richtig schön geschmeidig
ich habe nochmal etwa 20 bis 30 gramm
mehl dazu gegeben weil einfach die ein
bisschen größer waren
bist du einfach individuell schauen kurz
durchkneten also erzählte zwischen
richtig toller geschmeidiger teig ich
mache jetzt doch in vier strang zog aber
ihr könnt auch gerne drei stränge nur
machen
und jetzt wird jeder teil lang geformt
und es geht jetzt einfach auch am besten
wenn der teig noch nicht aufgegangen ist
und dann lasse ich ihn anschließend
einfach schön aufgeben
[Musik]
kann mir da macht neben mir jetzt auch
uns wir machen jetzt in vier strang zog
bei dem drei strangs oft kennt ihr das
er einfach von außen immer in die mitte
sowie bei dem haarzopf zb und jetzt
waren wir so an also das oben dass ich
einfach mal hier liegen
jetzt nehme ich den rechten strang der
kommt über den zweiten dann lege ich den
dritten hier drüber und der hier den ich
zuerst gelegt habe muss auch noch ganz
nach außen also rechter strang über den
zweiten dann der dritte oben drüber und
dann der zweite nochmals nach ganz links
außen
[Musik]
und jetzt könnt ihr entweder mit dem
normalen präferierten backbleche
arbeiten oder ihr nehmt zum beispiel
eine pizza blech das ist ja schon mal
schön rund dann hat man einfach schon
mal schön die form da lege ich nicht
dauernd folie rein und jetzt ganz
vorsichtig denn zu überheben und
transfair mich hinlegen müssen einfach
so ein bisserl in form ziehen und am
ende noch schön verbinden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hier in die mitte lege ich jetzt noch
einen bug ring und zwar deswegen damit
das loch in der mitte einfach schön frei
bleibt das brauche ich jetzt hier um so
schön aufgehen zu lassen ich habe es mit
bakterien spray gefettet damit einfach
ich den ring später wieder einfach weg
bekomme den kranz kann ich jetzt
abdeckung und für eine stunde aufgehen
lassen und sanierer macht den derzeit
kleine brötchen
der hefeteig ist jetzt sehr gut
aufgegangen wie ihr sehen könnte
explodiert förmlich und jetzt muss ich
noch die lauge herstellen dafür nehme
ich jetzt 200 milliliter wasser und 50
gramm natrium und zwar ist es ganz
normales kaiser thron aus dem supermarkt
ihr könnt natürlich auch aus der
apotheke oder aus der bäckerei richtige
natronlauge holen weiß man das problem
da muss man einfach sehr sehr gut
aufpassen denn die lauge darf weder in
die augen noch auf die haut noch auf die
arbeitsmaterialien und ich finde es
einfach entwickeln zu gefährlich wird
den hausgebrauch deswegen mache ich es
lieber mit kaiser natron hat man zwar
einen geringeren effekt was die lauge
betrifft aber das ist einfach ein
bisschen sicherer
jetzt kann man das ganze kurz aufkochen
lassen
normalerweise werden brezel und so
weiter dann eingetaucht da ich jetzt den
riesen kann es nicht eintauchen kann
werde ich ihn einfach verstreichen
[Musik]
und so schiebe ich jetzt den ganzen kopf
mit dem bug ring in den vorgeheizten
backofen bei 190 grad ober unterhitze
und da brauchen sie etwa 35 bis 40
minuten
jetzt schauen wir mal in den ofen rein
der laufen
da kann es das sieht schon richtig gut
auf ich habe jetzt auch die back
temperatur auf 170 grad herunter
gestellt und werde jetzt auch den ring
hier in der mitte entfernen da nehme ich
gleich einfach form messer dazu damit in
der mitte des rings ist einfach auch nur
ein bisschen farbe dran kann und jetzt
warte ich einfach nur noch bis die
backzeit fertig ist und dann bin ich
schon gespannt wie er schmeckt den
laufen kann habe ich direkt nach dem
backen mit back trance play besprüht so
hat er einfach einen schönen glanz
bekommen
jetzt habe ich ihn komplett abkühlen
lassen habe dafür einfach ein sauberes
kaschiert tuch darüber gelegt und jetzt
lasse ich ihn aber bis morgen ruhen denn
morgen ist dann mehr als
einschulungsfeier und dann werde ich ihn
einfach quer aufschneiden also mit einem
ganz großen brotmesser und den dann
verschiedene befüllen das heißt in einem
viertel deutschland bis lachs drauf ein
viertel business logic das ist schon
wahrscheinlich monats viertel ein
viertel mit käse ein viertel mit
frischkäse und dann kann man das
wirklich richtig schön bunt belegen und
am ende kann sich dann jeder einfach ein
bissle was runter schneiden
jetzt habe ich hier ein paar zutaten
gerichtet und werde zuerst einmal das
brot aufschneiden dann müsst ihr
natürlich ganz vorsichtig sein
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich den deckel runter der
klang manchmal nach hinten
so und jetzt habe ich hier eine große
fläche und werde jetzt einfach
verschiedene abteile machen das heißt
hier mache ich zum beispiel die portion
mit lachs situation mit ok die
vegetarische idee mit pokal und jetzt
können wir einfach dabei zuschauen wie
ich das brot lecker belege die ganzen
sachen habe ich jetzt bereits in
scheiben geschnitten
hier habe ich noch salat da ist bereits
gewaschen da wird jetzt noch
geschleudert damit einfach nicht so viel
flüssigkeit reinkommt und auch tomaten
werden jetzt auch verzichten damit ihr
nicht zu verwässern
denn dass wir das heute abend gegessen
das heißt heute mittag bleibt es dann im
kühlschrank dann gehen wir zusammen raus
einschulung und ja und dann darf das
heute abend machen und als grundlage
nämlich entweder frischkäse oder auch
ein keine butter
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich zuerst immer ein
bisschen salat so dass er bislang
rausguckt und schaue eben auch dass es
optisch sehr hübsch aussieht
[Musik]
zwiebeln und schnittlauch passen sehr
gut zum lachs was auch sehr gut passt
ist meerrettich dem nehme ich jetzt
nicht weil er auch ein bisschen schärfer
hat und die kinder die nicht so gerne
mögen
[Musik]
die habe ich jetzt ein viertel des fotos
mit etwas scheiben käse und paprika
belegt und jetzt kommt das nächste
viertel dran
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dieses viertel habe ich jetzt mit
frischkäse salatgurke etwas putenbrust
rucola und frühlingszwiebeln belegt das
letzte viertel habe ich jetzt mit
avocado belegt und die avocado dann mit
etwas zitronensaft beträufelt damit sie
nicht braun wird dann habe ich noch hart
gekochte eier drüber gelegt und mit salz
und pfeffer bestreuen
so gefällt mir richtig gut den werde ich
jetzt gleich mit dem deckel abdecken
diesen aber vorher auch mit butter und
mit frischkäse einstreichen
[Musik]
so sieht das gute stück jetzt aus und
ich sagen da kann es gefällt mir
wirklich sehr sehr gut und vor allem
richter total lecker damit jetzt
natürlich der kühlschrank nicht nach
lachs und putenbrust und zwiebeln riecht
wenn ich das ganze einfach mit einer
tüte einpacken und bis heute abend im
kühlschrank stellen und sobald wir von
der einschulungsfeier da sind kann dann
jeder sehe ich so eine scheibe
wegschneiden und einfach essen ja und
auf den resten gehe ich hier noch übrig
haben und hier zum beispiel noch
gekochte eier habe ich einfach bisschen
schnittlauch drauf macht heute abend
noch salz und pfeffer drüber und die
restlichen sachen also salat und
zwiebeln und so weiter
da mache ich einfach einen schönen
bunten salat draus machen noch ein
leckeres salatdressing 1
da habe ich ja auch schon ein video
online mit meinem drei lieblings
salatdressings und die werde ich dann zu
bereiten und dann kann jeder sich
einfach seinen lieblings dressing auf
unser nachgeben anschneiden werde ich
das jetzt nicht denn heute abend soll es
den ganzen sein aber ich denke ihr könnt
euch vorstellen wie gut es schmeckt und
wenn nicht dann packt doch denn ganz
einfach mal selber nach das rezept könnt
ihr auf einem kanal auf meinem blog
nachlesen auf sallys - klopp de
ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachbacken ihr müsst ihr auch nicht
einen 4 streng zu machen ihr könnt auch
nur drei stränge machen oder das ganze
irgendwie anders formen sowie ihr gerne
möchtet oder auch nur die hälfte zu
bereiten und einen kleineren dünneren
kampf machen egal wie es macht schickt
mir auf jeden fall ein foto und markiert
nicht auf instagram oder auf facebook
damit ich das auch sehen kann also viel
spaß dabei und bis zum nächsten mal
[Applaus]
[Musik]